it's completely reasonable to think that
there's life out there there's just so
many possibilities billions of stars and
billions of galaxies and other that it
uh surely there's life after finding
life even primitive microbial life would
change our place in the universe by
telling us that we're not alone
and it would most likely be an
indication that we're getting closer to
finding an intelligent civilization it
would be really fun if we could find an
alien that you know could send me an
email or Twitter or whatever all day
long but the profound question is is
life or non-life once we have the
microbial we have the potential for
intelligence but if we don't have a
life-form at all we don't have the
potential for anything but what if we do
find complex life out there what would
it look like would it be anything like
what we see in Hollywood movies it is
humorous that Hollywood depicts aliens
more or less the same way there's a
Klingon here and a Romulan there and
there's slanty eyes and you know big old
brains and so on any sort of alien that
resembles a human is ludicrous two eyes
a nose and a mouth there's no reason
that an alien would have to be adapted
this way over hundreds of millions of
years all the creatures of our planet
have adapted to their environment so the
chemistry's are similar
which means your genetic makeup isn't
all that different from an earthworm or
even your pet basically all animals are
worms for worms we got a head we got a
tail we're long and skinny and that's
how we move forward dinosaurs or worms
what people don't understand is that
evolution is not a road map humans are
not at the top of the evolutionary
ladder
we're not the end point the goal of
evolution or anything like that where
accidents we're random we eat through
our mouths but we can breathe through
our mouths and that means we can choke
on food that's a terrible design but
it's an accident of evolution maybe
aliens evolved a different thing maybe
they don't need to breathe maybe they
can get oxygen in some other way
anything like that can go as long as it
makes sense for the environment so life
on another planet would adapt to its
environment and could be stranger than
you could ever imagine it's fun to
speculate about how life might evolve
under conditions that are very different
from those here on the earth if you
lived on a planet with twice the gravity
of Earth there'd be a lot more pull on
your body and you'd come crashing down
twice as hard if you fell
so perhaps creatures there would have
stronger stockier bodies with more legs
closer to the ground a planet with very
little gravity would be like our Moon or
Mars
I can imagine a creature on a low
gravity planet as being long and spindly
life on a low gravity planet may be tall
and thin with long gangly legs if life
evolved on a very dense planet where the
atmosphere is soothly of water light you
could see creatures as big as whales or
elephants actually flying not through
the air but through this liquid like
atmosphere I think we are currently
ignorant actually about the real
realistic diversity of life elsewhere